hello everybody and welcome to episode
number two of my 02 one bill from
nothing
series thank you so much for all the
support I had in the last episode there
were tons of comments tons of likes and
you guys seem to like it and I really
enjoyed making it so we are on to
episode number two what our goals for
this episode are as we're going to try
to get fairy tales part one done as well
as uh hopefully pick some more my fungus
um the reason I'm doing fairy tales part
one is just so I can do some farming
later on and so I can have the fair
Rings which is required to do the more
mile fungus money-making method pretty
much um and yeah so to start off we need
to get lost city done uh so we need 31
crafting as well as some wood cutting
levels so we're going to start off by uh
crafting some leather and then do some
gold bars okay there is level seven
crafting so we can now move on to
crafting some gold amulets uh which is
actually a little bit profitable and so
now we're in Edgeville and we just got
all the gold bars and the amulet mold so
we're just going to be basically running
back and forth making the amulets I
think we get a couple hundred GP profit
per amulet which is always nice since we
have no money pretty poor so we'll do
this as long as we can okay there is
level 15
crafting not nothing else we're going to
do right now but uh we're going to get
to level 22 now actually then we're
going to make some games necklaces
there's level 20 crafting just a couple
more levels and we can make the games
necklace okay there's level 22 crafting
now we're going to go get some rubies or
some Sapphire sorry uh to make the
necklaces and and some runes as well so
as far as I'm aware I think we're going
to be getting about 400 GP in profit um
we bought the games necklace for
1,847 and all the components to do it I
think cost somewhere around 1,400 uh so
this seems decent um and we'll go do
this all the way till 31 crafting I
think okay there's level 31 crafting
that is a prerequisite for lost city all
done and we just have to do the rest of
the amulet so then we have to enchant
them too so this is a pain in the ass I
didn't realize this would be so so
annoying to do um so this probably isn't
worth it but we already have the runes
let's just enchant them all probably
would have been more profitable just to
make the Saar amulet and sell them but
whatever okay we're almost done and I
think we're actually going get a magic
level uh so that's kind of nice there's
30 magic not sure if there's anything
that gets us but anyway we're done this
so now on to wood cutting all right
there's level 15 wood cutting we can now
go cut oak trees this hopefully will be
a bit quicker cuz this took a while okay
there is level 20 wood cutting H get we
have to get 36 wood cutting so it's
going to be a little while but uh it's
going pretty quick there's level 25 wood
cutting I actually missed the exper or
the level up but anyway only nine more
levels and we're just about to get level
30 wood cutting any second now there it
is we're getting pretty close here we
can almost get the Adam axe equipped
which is kind of nice um but yeah only
six more levels okay so I think we're
just about to hit Level 36 wood cutting
uh we got some bird nest too which is
kind of nice oh my God we need to cut
one more tree uh so we'll see what we
get in there yeah we're 35 one more Oak
log and we will have the requirements
for lost city um so there it is we'll
open these bird nests as well um so
we'll get whatever we get in there um
but we also have to complete a couple
prerequisite
quests um I'm not sure what order we're
going to do we'll probably do like
Restless ghost that's a really easy one
oh Maple seed's actually worth like 10K
or something and a clue scroll okay not
too bad and yeah let's get on to
questing okay so we actually just need
the fador teleport and um I just thought
might as well get some magic levels
quickly so we're just en chanting some
dueling Rings uh which is actually
decent experience a little bit of money
too never hurts um but we're going to do
about 100 of these hopefully just gives
us to level 31 and there we are level 31
that was pretty easy uh we still have
some rings left to enchant uh so might
as well get rid of these okay so it
actually ended up getting us to level 32
magic probably got 10K in profit so
whatever uh we just need the magic level
pretty much so now we can go do a
Restless ghost we are just slapping the
skeleton down by kicking it um but yeah
that's pretty much it we'll just go back
and complete the quest okay we've
released the ghost from his eternal
unhappiness I guess and um yeah really
easy Quest only took like 3 minutes and
then we got some prayer experience as
well um I brought to level 10 prayer
that's kind of nice actually and now I
think we're going to do uh nature Spirit
or priest in Peril sorry so we're just
gearing up here we got the pure Essence
we'll need to give to him and some
energy potions so we can do this a bit
quicker um and yeah let's get started
with the quest okay we are pretty much
done um didn't record much of it cuz I I
just done so many times so we just have
to give them the rest of the runes and
that's pretty much it um there we go got
more prayer experience at Wolf Bane
dagger and access to canifis which is
most
important and uh also 15 prayer pretty
nice uh so now we're either going to do
lost city or nature Spirit not really
sure which one we're going to do next
yet okay so we decided to do nature
Spirit first uh we got all the gear in
our inventory re our requirements are
done we're bringing the wine with us cuz
apparently they can't rot wine which
does make sense um did not even know
that was a thing though and we have all
the items and yeah let's get started
with quest ah it's good to know they
can't actually rot the wine I didn't
actually know it was a thing oh my God
we we ran way past it while we were
distracted okay this is very slow with
this freaking sickle I feel like all
these quests I'm doing right now you
can't actually use a main weapon which
is a little Annoying and one more hit
and that's pretty much the quest
complete and another
zero okay there we are the spirit has
become a nature spirit and there we go
3,000 crafting experience 2,000 hit
points and 2,000
defense um what if that gives us any
levels and anything oh got us a crafting
level and a hit point level and a
defense level okay sweet so now on to
Lost City okay so we're going to Mage
the okay I can't actually equip that my
[__] okay I have to sell those back but
we're actually going to be maging the um
the boss from Lost City uh cuz it's not
in Trana and I don't have any range
levels so we got to Mage it pretty much
okay there we are we killed this tree
Spirit uh was really not too bad um
pretty easy with magic actually so we'll
cut a couple of these Draymond branches
I'm not sure if to drop them or not or
just keep chopping them probably um and
yeah that's lost city that Quest is way
quicker than I remember did not take
very long at all okay I think all we
have to do is go to zaris and then the
quest is complete we have a Draymond
staff let's see and there we go three
Quest points access to zerys most
importantly and yeah now we can pretty
much do
um uh what's the quest
called let's see if find it fairy tales
part one my bad and yeah we can start
that pretty much anytime okay we got all
the items I think we need I got some
teleports and yeah I think we're just
going to start it right now okay we are
on to fight the tangle foot I not
confident at all I can kill this H I
didn't even have enough lobsters fill up
my inventory so we're going to have to
see how this goes oh I don't know about
this he's hitting 10 and 11s on me and I
can hit like a Max of three
this is going to be kind of close I
don't actually know if I can do this at
all I might have to come back with
something else okay so we figured out
he's kind of dumb and we can just run
back and forth and kind of hit and run
him so I think we'll be able to do this
cuz otherwise we definitely would have
died wa you don't even have to run you
can just walk back and
forth this guy is not particularly smart
but he is almost
dead H this has taking so
long there we go he is dead there's a
queen seers and that is fair Tales part
one pretty pretty much all done there we
go 3500 farming experience 2,000 attack
XP and 1,000 magic pretty decent got us
all the way to level 17 farming and yeah
now we just have to start fairy tales
part two and we have access to the fairy
rings so we started the fairy tales part
two Quest um but we have to get some
prayer levels pretty much for the mort
my fungus moneymaking method plus we
have to wait like 10 minutes to come
back and see if his crops are dead um
you actually have to wait like five
in-game minutes or something like that
so we're going to go get our prayer
level up quickly okay so if I recall you
just have to use them on here and yeah
you get a ton of prayer experience uh
we're starting at 16 and we'll see what
these 100 bones will get us to okay
that's not even the inventory of Bones
gone and we're already level 25 prayer
that is so quick we got protect from
item which is nice there's level 30
prayer still got another inventory to go
I believe okay and that is all the bones
used it got us all the way to level 37
prayer which actually is enough for
protect from Magic which is cool okay so
we're just pretty much starting off the
fairy tales part two Quest you don't
need any requirements to do this uh for
the the second part of the quest you
literally just have to go do a couple
things and then you'll have access to
the fairy rings which is nice uh I don't
have to do this quest for quite a while
and yeah we'll just finish this up
quickly okay there we go you can see we
can use the fairy rings already honestly
just takes 10 minutes to just start the
quest off and then yeah you can travel
pretty much anywhere you want so what
we're doing is now we have the silver
sickle we've gone to the morm fungus or
swamp sorry and we're getting the morm
fungus they're worth about 1,000 coins
each and yeah basically just cast this
Bloom spell pick him up I think I'm in
the wrong spot right now so we'll go
find a better spot but um yeah pretty
decent money apparently 5 or 600k an
hour okay we're just going to check what
we can actually sell them for and yeah
we sold them for over 1,000 each um86 so
pretty good we'll continue doing this
okay so we found the proper place so you
can see here I can actually get three at
the time I actually manag to get a full
inventory um cuz my prayer level is not
very high unfortunately uh so I don't
generally get a full inventory but I
almost did there um and yeah so we're
going to do for like half an hour or
something there's a big storm coming so
I have to pretty much get this uploaded
in case my internet goes down um so
we'll do like half an hour this and see
how it goes okay we are back and we
managed to get about 210 Mort my fungus
in about 25 minutes so I think we could
easily get 5 or 600k an hour it seems
pretty accurate uh but unfortunately I
think that's what we're going to have to
call it the episode for today um big
storm coming in like I said my internet
could probably go down at any time
wouldn't be able to get up for 3 days
after that uh so we're going to upload
now even know we didn't actually
progress
much by getting much money we have
completed quite a few quests got our
prayer level up we invested about 300K
into that and we'll get about another
240k back from these more my funguses so
next episode I will definitely grind
this out we'll get a couple mil
hopefully and maybe I'll show you
exactly the route I'm taking to do this
and yeah hope you guys enjoyed again if
you want to leave a like really awesome
last time we got tons of likes tons of
comments and yeah really awesome thanks
guys for watching and I'll see you guys
in episode number three
[Music]